lamar jackson along with baker mayfield
josh allen and sam darnold all eligible
for their second contract there's been
some chatter about that in recent days
here's eric decosta the ravens gm
earlier today talking about lamar
jackson and whether or not he deserves a
second contract
i will be talking along lamar probably
within the next 10 days or so he's down
in florida
but uh we've got a great relationship
he's got a great relationship with this
organization
he's a very easy person to talk to and
certainly
deserves a contract
he has played phenomenal football over
the last couple of years
and our intention and my intention is to
keep him in baltimore for many many
years
interesting dynamics with lamar jackson
number one he doesn't have an agent now
some of the guys who have no agent truly
have no agent others who don't have an
agent actually have an agent who isn't
really an agent isn't an authorized
certified nflpa agent but does the work
maybe at an hourly rate not at a
percentage fee and this whole no agent
trend has arisen from the idea that guys
don't want to give up one or two or up
to three percent of their salary
to someone who will get them a hell of a
lot more than the 100 they would get on
their own which is just
i don't want to
i don't want to start down that path
that's not what it's about but the point
is as it relates to lamar jackson
without an agent it puts the ravens in a
position where they could maybe do a
team-friendly deal especially with the
salary cap in the range of 180 million
hey lamar you want some financial
security you're not going to make much
money this year here's what we'll do
here's what we can do we can't do more
than that because the cap's going to be
too low there is an opportunity there to
kind of subtly finesse a team-friendly
deal with lamar jackson at least over
the next few years
if you don't get that deal that you're
looking for as a team mike you kick you
can down the road just like the cowboys
did with that prescott and say okay
we'll hold out and wait which is what i
think they should do frankly and i think
you agreed with me on this i i want to
see more from lamar jackson in the
postseason one and three in the
postseason three touchdowns five
interceptions he's been great in the
regular season we know that nobody has
more wins in the regular season since
he's became the full-time starter since
lamar jackson does he's been terrific he
has an mvp award but mike this run
reminds me so
much of the ravens and joe flacco coming
off that super bowl mvp award the ravens
made
joe flacco the highest paid player in
football and after that they went 42 and
41 made one playoff appearance and were
one and one in the postseason with joe
flacco it did not work out i want to see
more from lamar jackson if i'm the
ravens before i commit that kind of
money and that kind of length of
contract to lamar jackson
the injury risk is a big part of it as
well and they've got him for another
year of his base rookie deal and then
they have the fifth year option now the
new cba revises the fifth year option a
bit i think he'll be eligible for
franchise tag money
even though he was the 32nd pick change
the formula for first round picks based
upon how often you play how much you
accomplish in your first
four years or three years in the nfl but
they'll they'll pick up the fifth year
option by may 3rd
and they'll have that certainty the
question though then becomes
what do they do and when do they do it
as it relates to a long-term deal and
you know
at some point
there is i think some wisdom in just
letting a guy hit the market
i even if you want to try to sign him on
the open market i mean sometimes a guy
wants too much
and it's not going to be out there you
know i've said that with the cowboys
prior to the injury
prior to the
franchise tender you know the whole
concept of the franchise tag is it takes
a guy off the market it keeps the guy
from hitting the open market and if the
cowboys don't want to pay dak prescott a
long-term deal driven by the amount of
the franchise tag can just let him hit
the market and see what the market bears
and
try to sign him
if someone else you know offers x you
offer x plus one
um but you know roll the dice and see if
you think that the market's not going to
be out there for him and i think for a
guy like a margin lamar jackson i don't
know what the market would be i don't
know that somebody would offer him 40 45
50 million years sims and i discussed
recently shireen our belief that
moving forward there will be tiers of
quarterback contracts it's no longer
going to be this is the next guy who's
up for a contract so he just becomes the
highest paid quarterback in league
history until the next one there was
like a a cascading effect of that a few
years ago when it went from
derek carr to andrew luck to matthew
stafford to jimmy garoppolo to kirk
cousins to matt ryan to aaron rodgers
and and patrick holmes kind of changed
that but i think there really are the
best of the best and they're going to
have their range the next cut they're
going to have their range the next cut
they're going to have their range that's
going to be the only fair way to do it
because because i just think you know
you put lamar jackson on the open market
right now well definitely he's not
getting 45 million definitely not in
this climate but i think that's just
part of the the analysis the ravens have
to engage in
yeah no question about it mike and you
know
they need to help him too and i know
eric decosta talked today about well we
don't think we necessarily need a number
one receiver well you know it it says
she does the sets say you do you were
32nd
passing for whatever reason yes you
threw the fewest passes but that was
probably more by design than anything
else but they've got to improve that
passing game mike if they're going to
compete for a super bowl in this day and
age you can't be number one in passing
and 32nd i'm sorry number one in rushing
and 32nd and passing and win a super
bowl that's not the way this game is
played and i know they're not going to
change their offense and that's fine
it's worked very well in the regular
season but they have to be better at
passing the football in the postseason
if they're going to win a super bowl
it's as simple as that i mean it's not
rocket science to figure that out you've
seen it you've seen it now in three post
seasons with this team they've got to
pass the ball better and score more
points
yeah i agree with you completely and
it's just one of the things you're gonna
have to figure out if they want to get
to the next level there's just teams out
there that feel like they're bumping up
against the ceiling packers ravens
vikings it's a lower ceiling for them
cowboys it's even lower than that but
how do you start busting through these
ceilings and for the ravens the key is
getting a passing game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports